this is clay mine came from the store
but you could even dig it up yourself
from the earth where the soil contains
clay minerals when you bake it it
becomes hard so you can make an
assortment of random objects but people
much more talented than me have been
using it for thousands of years for
things like pottery and buildings and
clay was even the first known writing
medium i find it delightful to be able
to look at ancient clay tablets from the
babylonians 4 000 years ago many of them
are mathematical and show an amazing
level of knowledge and accuracy
scribes were taught how to record the
information onto the clay add a kind of
scribe school and it is within the
relics of these schools that we can find
the first known homework assignments
what's great is that it's actually not
too hard to read these tablets for
ourselves the numbers are marked in the
clay with a wedged tool
this is one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
and this is ten
so
twenty
thirty
forty
fifty
and since they're using base sixty
this symbol is again 60 so it could be
60 or 1 depending on its place within
the number
to get the hang of it let's start with
the work of a first-year student at
scribe school where the writing is a lot
larger and clumsier than the more
accomplished students
these are some relatively easy
multiplication exercises
in the first row we have 50
multiplied by 45
we would normally work that out to be
2250 in our number system but the answer
written here looks like 37
30.
we can go ahead and see that this is
indeed the same as what we would get
since there is no symbol for zero the
place values are up for some
interpretation but for this one the 30s
is essentially the ones position and 37
is the 60s
so
37 times 60
plus 30 is equal to 2250.
at school we often have to memorize the
multiplication tables but something that
all scribe students would have had to
memorize is a table of reciprocals which
would make division a lot easier
this is an example of one such table
written by a student but apparently
there are so many errors in it that an
angry teacher has crossed it out
completely on both sides
these tables would list that one-third
of 60 is 20. one-fourth of 60 is 15
a fifth is 12 a sixth is 10
and so on
60 is a great base to use because it
divides into lots of numbers exactly
to divide by any number on this table
you just have to multiply by the
reciprocal
but if your teacher is a big meanie they
might want you to divide by a weird
number like 7 or 13 which 60 doesn't
divide exactly into
these kind of problems are a lot harder
and you see an example of one of these
questions on this tiny little tablet
here
it's small and can fit easily in the
palm of your hand and it was likely
intended for a student of scribe school
to take it home with them to complete
and return to the teacher with the
solution
it is one of our earliest ever examples
of homework
it asks the student to show that
1
1
1 1
divided by
for us that number is 1
plus 60 plus 60 squared plus 60 cubed
which is two hundred and nineteen
thousand six hundred and sixty one
that we will want to divide by thirteen
and for us doing it on a calculator that
gives 16
897.
the answer shown on the tablet converted
to our number system is 37 plus
41 times 60
plus four times sixty squared which is
the same sixteen thousand eight hundred
and ninety seven
the babylonian students would likely
have had to solve this by doing 60 cubed
60 squared
60 and 1 all individually divided by 13
and adding up the results and the
remainders
i just find it amazing that not only
were they doing pretty hard math
problems but the way they recorded their
working and answers are so simple that
we can actually understand and replicate
them thousands of years later
quick thank you to caystify for
sponsoring this portion of today's video
now if i wanted my clay replicas to look
a bit more authentic i might add some
scratches or damage to them but to
prevent my phone from getting the same i
have a protective case on it now i'm
actually stoked to be working with
casetify for this video because it is
through them that i've honestly received
the best cases i've ever had the one i
have on my phone right now is the impact
case which is slim and made from a shock
absorbing chi tech material
it's rated drop proof up to 6.6 feet but
for even more protection there is the
ultra impact case rated drop proof up to
9.8 feet what really attracted me to
this brand though are the designs they
are some of the nicest i've seen which
you can also customize or add your own
writing
these are made from 50 recycled
materials with an antimicrobial coating
and this one is fully compostable if you
have a newer iphone you can also get a
magsafe compatible case so it works with
wireless charging so if you'd like to
get a case for yourself be sure to go to
casetify.com
tippies today to get 15 off your order
and i'll put that link in the
information down in the description what
got me interested in babylonian math
again recently was a paper that was
published a few weeks ago by an
australian mathematician who had
discovered the oldest known example of
applied geometry the tablet si427
shows land boundaries and was drawn by a
scribe who would have graduated school
and gone out into the field
practical issues of land ownership sales
and taxes
is after all exactly what a scribe would
have trained for the land in question is
split into very precise shapes but to
make truly perpendicular lines was not
trivial
and something that is pretty special
about this tablet is that it shows the
babylonians using pythagorean triples in
order to ensure that the perpendicular
lines do indeed meet at right angles
it is pythagoras's theorem that says in
a right angle triangle a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared
and a pythagorean triple is three
positive integers that meet this
condition
such as three four and five
this tablet was made at least a thousand
years before pythagoras was even born
but the concept was also used in india
and china before then so pythagoras was
hardly the first person to invent the
idea anyway here you can see a triangle
with sides
seven
thirty
eighteen and nineteen thirty
for us that's seven and a half eighteen
and nineteen and a half which is a
scaled pythagorean triple
it's just 1.5 times the triple
5 12 13.
this rectangle here has the same
dimensions
and was probably used to keep these
sides in equal length which could then
be extended to make the rest of the
boundaries
this discovery of how they used
pythagorean triples was only published a
few weeks ago but we had already known
that they knew trigonometry from another
babylonian tablet plimpton322
a list of pythagorean triples together
with the information needed to resize
them
this list likely belonged to a teacher
maybe at one of the scribe schools and
served as a powerful reference
the fact we are still learning so much
about this ancient civilization and how
they did mathematics is really exciting
here are a few more fascinating homework
problems this palm size tablet shows a
circle drawn inside a square
and we believe the question for the
student was to find the side length of
the square given the shortest distance
from the circle to the square
and the area of the region between the
circle and the square
if we label that area b the distance d
which is written on there as 15
the side length of the square as s
and r as the radius of the circle then
we have these two equations
that the area of the square minus the
area of the circle is b
and that two times the distance plus two
times the radius of the circle is the
side length of the square we can
eliminate the variable r
and then doing a bit of work to get a
quadratic that can be solved for s
for this problem the babylonian
approximation of pi was 3
and we've been able to figure out that
the value of b was likely given as what
we would call
2376.5625
the quadratic was one that seemed fairly
tricky so i used wolfram outfit to solve
it and that gave me the answer of 52 and
a half which matches up with what you'll
see written on the top left of the
tablet it says 5230
and on the tablet you'll also find that
value squared which is the total area of
the square
isn't it amazing that this slab of such
ancient clay can help us here in 2021 to
sharpen our math skills even without
understanding any of the historical or
cultural context of when it was written
another amazing little tablet is this
one here
ybc7289 contains an approximation for
the square root of two which is accurate
to six decimal places
and that's the greatest known
computational accuracy found anywhere in
the ancient world the square root of two
is an infamous number it's irrational it
goes on forever and can't be written as
the ratio of two integers the rumor goes
that pythagoras and his squad were so
shocked by this concept that they
drowned a guy at sea for so much as
suggesting it but here are the
babylonians a thousand years earlier
assigning it for homework they have a
square with side length one
and that makes a triangle where we can
use what we call pythagoras's theorem to
find the hypotenuse squared by adding up
the squares of both the sides in this
case the hypotenuse squared is one plus
one
so the hypotenuse is the square root of
two the number given here on the tablet
is 1 24
51 10
which as a decimal is 1.414213
so now we know the ratio of the diagonal
to the side of any square and can scale
it on the tablet one side is labeled 30
and say for example we wanted to find
the diagonal of a square with side
length 30 we would just do 30 times the
square root of 2 and doing that gives us
the last number here on the tablet 42 25
35 which is 42.426
for us
so i guess maybe it's worth taking some
care with your homework assignments just
in case they get studied by historians
in the future and used to make judgments
on how advanced your entire society was
apparently only half the tablets still
in existence have been translated so i'm
sure we will find plenty more
interesting stories within them
and if you want to discover something
new for yourself then perhaps it is a
topic worth pursuing further i've listed
all of my sources down in the
description thanks for watching this
video and thanks to my patreons for
supporting my channel and a special
shout out to today's patreon cat of the
day who is looking awfully dog-like
moe
you